well i'll be honest when i first seen
the reports of of the president going to
places like iran and venezuela to ask
for more oil output
i said this is fake news
there's he hasn't gone this far off the
rocker but you know i guess apparently
that's the path they want to take and
i'm asking you know
why not an invite north korea maybe they
got a few barrels of oil that they can
spare you know is
the supply of oil so important that it's
acceptable to cut deals in some cases
with countries that may have engaged in
unsavory actions in the past but is it
really worth doing business
with a despot like nicholas maduro to
drive down gas prices and you guys think
that asking saudi arabia or venezuela or
iran is reducing our dependence on
foreign oil
we hate that it's taking a war in
ukraine and the suffering of their
people to bring this to the full
attention but we tried to warn this
administration
back when they canceled the keystone
pipeline that
it wasn't just the keystone pipeline you
were canceling national security foreign
policy and energy they're all kind of
that they go hand in hand and when you
cancel that pipeline uh you put us in
this position that we uh
we're facing today and if you look at it
these prices were headed higher to begin
with even with
outer war in ukraine and even if we can
fix the ukrainian problem the prices are
still going up i don't see
an end to it as long as biden is using
this uh
anything any way but an american way
when it comes to fossil fuels it ain't
just from shutting down the keystone
pipeline it's not just from canceling
federal releases but i've been lucky
enough
since the cancellation of the keystone
pipeline i've sitting on four different
congressional meetings
and uh this is the thing the public
don't hear a lot about you know you hear
the white house press secretary up there
today saying that well why don't we ask
the energy companies why they're not
using these 9 000 leases that are
available well here's the facts
there's no energy company going to spend
the money to develop the new lease if
they can't build a pipeline to move the
project and that's the kind of things
that are taking place behind the scenes
gensake your policies your boss's
policies have everything to do with the
rising fuel prices in this country today
it has nothing to do with a war in
ukraine the very first thing my
recommendation would be we've got to get
the administration's foot off the
throats of the energy companies and let
them do what they do best
we're not saying to help build windmills
or solar farms
start building them have fun do it do it
it'll be part of the energy sector but
don't kill the part of the economy and
and what we depend on right now is what
i'm saying
we don't know when we'll be able to make
that switch but right now this country
runs on oil and gas
and it makes no sense for the americans
to suffer higher prices for it i've kind
of seen the writing on the wall the last
few years with our lack of development
and new infrastructure and i knew this
was a matter of time before uh
we're about to see uh price increases
that
i can't see the end to it to tell you
the truth of
you know seven eight dollars a barrel
with a surprise or a gallon for gas
wouldn't surprise me in the future